[Música]
mi primer cosplay fue de Leonardo de las
Tortugas Ninja Fue en un Halloween hace
casi 30
he estado haciendo cosplay bastante
tiempo mi primer cosplay fue
unalis y he estado haciendo cosplay
durante unos 10 años he estado haciendo
cosplay durante unos tres años y mi
primer cosplay fue Mercy de overwatch
genial genial he estado haciendo cosplay
desde lax 2011 mi primer cosplay fue el
entrenador Pokémon Rojo he estado
haciendo cosplay durante ocho años mi
primera convención fue cosplay con me
disfracé de Satanás llevo dos años
haciendo cosplay mi primer cosplay fue
yuki de Vampire Knight me uní al
ejército me enviaron a Japón había
muchos cosplayers y ahora estoy aquí
haciendo esto a tiempo completo he
estado haciendo cosplay durante unos 12
años estoy disfrazada de Bernard en
Santa Claus me encanta esa película Mi
primer cosplay fue lo siento fe Fiona de
Adventure Time
Oh pueden explicarnos porque ustedes no
hicieron cosplay Cuando entré y vi que
el otro caballero y yo éramos los únicos
chicos que no teníamos cosplay dije
estamos tengo mi máscara del Hombre
Araña hago cosplay como maíz Morales
todo el tiempo de hecho estoy semi
disfrazado porque tengo el traje de
civil de él y los zapatos también como
ven me puse la sudadera con capucha
tenía una máscara si puedes comprar una
máscara y demostrar que eres un fanático
de este personaje no significa que seas
un cosplayer pero mi primer cosplay fue
de Capitán América e hice un escudo
firmado por Stanley Sí dijo que comenzó
a hacer cosplay como Leonardo pero luego
dijo que su primer cosplay fue el
Capitán América Así que las cosas no
parecen estar encajando también estoy en
el ejército
Así es soy un oficial eso me inspiró a
ser el Capitán América pero todos
pensaban que yo era su compañero no
puedo recordar su nombre
tengo un almacén cerca donde guardo mis
cosas cuando no las uso debido al covid
no he estado en nada excepto el alla
este año aquí pueden ver mi carnet y en
un día fui a buscar algo y el almacén se
inundó solo conseguí disfraces mojados y
mojosos pero en general he hecho cosplay
de todos los personajes de personas
solía dirigir las reuniones de cosplay
de frases a veces los hago pero por lo
general los compro por internet para
simplificar las cosas sin complicaciones
solo quiero estar cómodo eso es muy raro
sí hay una laca para el cabello común
que usamos en la comunidad cosplay 1 2 3
y es amarillo
[Risas]
estaba pensando que tal vez es un
organizador de convenciones y por eso
conoce muy bien a la comunidad
note que la chica del cosplay de samus
tenía guantes lo que significaba que no
podía usar su teléfono nadie en una
convención quiere lidiar con eso
[Música]
Adiós
Lo siento Ryan Entonces cuál es su tipo
de cosplay y hacen sus cosas compran sus
cosas ahorran sus cosas de hecho estoy
tratando de aprender a hacer mis propios
cosplays a veces voy a una tienda local
fui a Rose una vez y compré una malla
hice un cosplay de
esperen Lo siento estoy teniendo una
laguna mental y sea y atrapenenosa y que
hay con este lo compraste en la tienda o
es este es de Mac costums yo hice esta
camisa y el bolso y uso mi propio
cabello natural porque tengo
lo hice con mi papá somos un Dúo
pleno y usamos una pistola de aire
caliente vaya también cucharones para
darle forma Yo diría que estoy en el
medio porque soy nueva en el cosplay Así
que hice las muñequeras y los zapatos
peiné un poco la peluca pero compré el
traje Cuando empecé no era muy buena
cociendo ni haciendo utilería Sí hago
mucho de mi cosplay ahora por desgracia
este lo compré Y qué hay de ti
reacondicioné mi traje de Capitán
América con mis ahorros del ejército e
hice mi escudo con un trineo pero solo
pagué 45 dólares por todo el equipo todo
lo elige usé mi Sierra de calar para
cortarlo así que los haces los compras o
no solo lo hice con cosas que ya tenía
en casa Y qué hay de tu primer cosplay
dijiste que fue hace unos 30 años Fue
Leonardo y entre esos hiciste algo más
Sí mi experiencia de cosplay real fue en
una convención en Chicago Cada cuánto
haces cosplay cada año
fuiste al Anime Expo este año
en julio la anime es al final del mes
una que fue hace unos meses
creo que es un anime con diferente
[Música]
está bien
todas las mujeres me atacaron no hay
Piedad para mí sabía que iba a estar
fuera triste pero cierto si creen que el
impostor Todavía está en la caja y
desean continuar jugando levanten la
mano
Cuáles son algunas cosas que más Le
encantan de la comunidad y cuáles no les
gustan porque hablo por mí me ha hecho
tener confianza en mí misma por suerte
pero hay algunas cosas que no me gustan
de la comunidad de cosplay cosplay no es
así me toques No me digas cosas
desagradables soy una persona real pero
lo sé tú muy cierto para mí la gente
siempre tiene problemas con un tono de
piel recibo comentarios desagradables
todo el tiempo es como si no tuviera
representación tal como esta no hay
muchos personajes que se parezcan a mí
al final del día me mantendré firme en
esto y lo seguiré haciendo sin importar
nada aparte de eso me encanta el hecho
de que las personas se defiendan entre
sí realmente me encanta eso de las
comunidades para seguir con lo que estás
diciendo la gente dice acaso desanime
conócete siempre No puedo creerlo en
primer lugar sí en segundo acaso te
importa Si estás interesado en algo ya
sea en la estética o en otra cosa Vive
tu vida por eso estamos aquí me gusta
que otros tengan Conocimiento es una
comunidad muy especializada en la que
puedes encontrar gente saber de qué
hablar y solo comenzar una conversación
diría que aquí en los Estados Unidos no
es tan malo en línea son más abiertos
pero cuando publico mis cosas cuando van
a la comunidad de Asia porque soy de
allí todo siempre dicen se ve feo y
cosas así es como Oh sí no cómo entraste
al cosplay ella o yo tú Yo siempre me
han gustado mucho los videojuegos y
estaba empezando a interesarme más en el
anime Así que parecía algo natural y
divertido vestirme como los personajes
que me gustan tanto y es muy divertido
sentí que ella insistía en terminar la
ronda y todavía no estaba lista para
terminar
no sé me sentí mal al elegir
la resulta que hay un empate
el empate es entre hay y Samanta
voy a darles a cada una 30 segundos para
exponer su caso de Por qué no son la
impostora soy de Indonesia y vine aquí
hace unos años no sé qué decir mi peor
crisis de con Crunch fue Cuando hice
Harley Quinn y luego hice ese personaje
de Lane y estaba llorando porque mi
máquina de coser se descompuso y
entonces terminé teniendo que dejar uno
de ellos porque no pude terminar el
disfraz Así que lloré mucho esta noche
Supongo que empezaré con mi peor con
Crush en realidad fue este cosplay
estaba pintando los zapatos dando los
toques finales a las líneas en el auto y
de camino decía conduce más rápido pero
estuvo bien he estado haciendo cosplay
por solo unos tres años Así que todavía
estoy aprendiendo a mejorar un poco mi
destreza pero hasta ahora ha sido un
viaje divertido
lo único que me preocupa es que tal vez
sea comisionada o algo así Eso es lo
único ella podría ser la que lo fabrica
Samanta es más nueva y no quiero
quedarme con eso es lo que me preocupa
cuando nos haya también hace sus trajes
estaba diciendo que lo estaba logrando
lo está haciendo aquí porque entonces
podría haberlo intentado aquí y en
realidad hace otro modelaje hay más de
que hablar siento que tenía muchas cosas
que hay quería decir
y la persona eliminada es
Está bien buena suerte
Te ves muy bien si creen que el impostor
sigue en la caja y desean continuar
jugando levanten la mano
Confío en ustedes me siento tan mal
eliminando yo también siento que no
deberíamos haber hecho la última ronda
no
rojas eso significa que el impostor
sigue en la caja y pierden si las luces
se vuelven verdes eso significa que han
eliminado al impostor y ganan
bien entonces quién era podría el
impostor dar un paso al frente
Lo siento
cualquiera que haya hecho cosplay lo
suficiente nunca querría caminar con
esos tacones durante todo el día
entonces acabas de comprar todo eso como
usted esto para Halloween hace cinco
años y no tenía los zapatos los acabo de
hacer el con Cruz que dije era viniendo
aquí algo me olía mal Mi sentido
hay mucho trabajo relacionado con el
cosplay que incluso con toda mi
investigación sobre el tema realmente
nunca hubiera sabido yo era una de las
personas que amaba grupos en línea
tomábamos fotos grupales y era una
excelente manera de conocer personas que
tenían ideas afines amaban y se
obsesionaban de las mismas cosas que yo
somos nerds y nos estamos volviendo loco
podría ser médico bombero estar en el
ejército puedes encontrarte con un
cosplayer donde sea cuando vas a un
lugar donde puedes saltar a algo en lo
que estás muy muy interesado viste la
nueva actualización te gustó la nueva
temporada mientras que en una
conversación a veces es hasta doloroso
tener una pequeña charla Esa es la parte
buena del cosplay para mí
obtienes un dólar obtienes un dólar
obtienes un dólar